can we relive the moment uh we recently
just re-watched the episode where you
got hit by some dude at a bar yeah how
did that go down why did it happen what
happened to the guy
um so we were at a bar and there was
this drunk [__] she was so [__]
annoying like you know drunk guys like
just like too much
but just like just like not even just
like a regular guy just like a tool like
he's already a tool to begin with and
then he's drunk and then he's just like
so dramatic so he kept like pushing us
and I was ordering shots
and I was ordering shots for all of us
and he took the shots that I ordered so
I was like all right fine whatever but
at that time we're paying for it with
our 200 that we got from the T-shirt
shop so I'm like come on so then I
ordered another shot
um for all of us and he ended up taking
it again so I was like can you stop
taking our shots like this is for me and
then he like said something and I was
like you're an ugly [__] like you know
whatever and then all of a sudden he
just turned and punched me in the face
and I felt like I got hit by a ton of
bricks did you guys like a small girl
did you get knocked out I think I got
knocked out for a second yeah yeah and
did you remember falling to the floor
that's wild and then I woke up like five
seconds later
and I was like oh [__] and I thought
like I thought my jaw was broken I
thought all my teeth were gone and I'm
like oh [__] and they uh
played it Isaac just played it on the TV
they didn't blur his face or anything so
everybody well they blurted out for the
first two seasons
yeah so it was like a good fun night
yeah so but what happened to the guy
afterwards does he get arrested yeah
well oh so bad
wow yeah but uh I seem to recall the the
Jersey Shore boys kind of mopping up and
going to go of course well Jenny was the
OG because she started slapping him in
the face like Jenny Jenny beat up
anybody that pissed her off so she she
got him good in the face and then the
boys were trying to get to him but
obviously the cops arrested him whatever
but yeah he lost his job I guess he was
a gym teacher lost his job and then his
father did an interview like two years
later or two years two years ago and he
blamed me for ruining his son's life
because he cannot get a job anymore I
was like why is that my fault you're
gonna punched me in the face I'm
drinking at a lot of bars and and like
my whole drinking career I've never seen
the dude hit a chick like that yeah it's
it's insane back then I was like oh [__]
like like I wanted to go home I was like
what the [__] am I doing like this has
never happened before but looking back
at it now that's what made all the big
hype about our show like oh my god did
you see the little girl get punched in
the bar on this reality show now would
that happen a lot would like if you guys
went out to party for a night would the
locals be trying to fight every single
night because they see all these cameras
and you guys are getting all the
attention yeah yeah so season three was
really bad because they knew if we got
into a fight with them and one of us hit
them they would try and sue us happened
so many times so it was it was bad like
and they get to be on TV yeah so
everyone was just using us to get our
money and then get on TV so it was
really hard to go out
yeah I wonder how many lawsuits Jersey
Shore had I think there were a couple
none against me but yeah
like shopping on Amazon I do and good
news is Stevo's butt wipes for your
butthole are available on Amazon and if
you want a real bundle of a deal you can
get Stevo's hot sauce for your butthole
plus Stephen's butthole destroyer and
Stevo's butt wipes for your butthole
it's the butthole bundle available on
Amazon right now yeah